let's talk about ratchet let's go over
here so tell me about this ryan murphy
rule because a lot of actors of your
caliber have jumped into ryan murphy's
world so what's it like for you to get
into this
universe that he has going well i feel
lucky
yeah and i feel blessed because
he's a good good human
who's doing good good things he's taken
all of these people the diverse people
which frankly the diverse people become
the majority of the people
the people over 40 the black and brown
people
the um lgbtq people
all of these people and put them to work
and so he's got more shows on the air
than anybody else and more watchers
than anybody else because all of us
diverse
people are the majority
of the audience which some people
seem to fail to understand the logic of
that
i know i know but be honest with me
sharon how was it working with that
monkey
so fun was it yeah really fun and really
nice
and i do really miss him
it's like you know how i don't know do
you have any pets
i used to have a dog but no monkey but i
genuinely believe that my dog
understands me when i talk to him except
when i tell him to stop licking me and
get off the couch
but otherwise total understanding
but when you work with a primate there
is more than just
you see them have a compassionate
understanding like your pets really do
seem to have a compassionate
understanding
and you of them but when you work with a
primate
they actually have verbal understanding
right and an intellectual grasp of
what's going on
so if i say to him you know it's okay
for you to
throw the biscuits at me he throws the
biscuits at me
if i say you can be really crazy in this
scene
he would pick up his skirt and show me
his
ass in the scene which was
hilarious you know
i told someone else this i just think
it's so funny the one thing he loved was
smoking out of the
cigarette holder so i had to watch him
not to smoke
when i put the cigarette down and left
the scene i'd be like and don't let me
come back and see you smoking
that's awesome all right because smoke
smokes cigarettes yeah this this might
be
me connecting the dodge too much but
obviously michael douglas executive
produced this obviously the executive
produce one flow over the cooper's nest
given your guys history
do you have a conversation with him
before you do this project is that
something that you do
well in this particular case i didn't
have an opportunity to talk to him yet
but
we've been friends and we've been
friends for the entire time
since i had this great break from him
long long ago
um i'm a huge um i don't think
fan is the maybe word it's more
like he's a he's an iconic
uh mentor to me the things that he has
done
with his career and his life where he
understands that playing the villain is
a really cool part and a power part
he's not afraid to take the bad guy part
and he's also uses the
momentum that he gets to work on things
of great value
out in the world and gets a lot of
really important things done
and i've always admired that about him
tremendously yeah
what do you think is going to surprise
people about this because obviously they
know nurse ratchet right but this is a
whole world created around her
so what do you think people are going to
be surprised with this well i think
they're going to be surprised that
they're
that a woman like nurse ratchet had a
life outside of that hospital
and something happened prior to that and
this is what i
also particularly like about ryan is
that he shows people's humanity
in other ways that you never imagined
that they could have humanity
because again this group of us that
wasn't in this
isolated you could see this at the
movies group
um how all have humanity
and that humanity is incredibly
interesting and it's incredibly
interesting to the audience
because like it's like
or it's reminiscent of or it reminds you
of
and so or it makes you chuckle because
of
and so there's all these things that
have yet to be
explored that we're all very much
entrenched in
because it's about our lives so it's
just
a tremendous amount of material
ryan's so amazing yeah well
congratulations on this i loved you on
the show so congratulations sharon
great to talk to you thank you take care